the fbi doing damage control over the
way it first characterized a harrowing
terror attack on a synagogue in texas a
british national storming into the place
of worship taking four hostages while
demanding the release of a prisoner
known as lady al-qaeda the gunman killed
after an 11-hour standoff thankfully all
the hostages were able to escape
physically unharmed but here's how the
fbi initially described the motive
we do believe from our engagement with
this subject that he was singularly
focused on one issue
and it was not specifically related to
the jewish community but we're
continuing to work to find motive and we
will continue on that path
after backlash the fbi doing a 180 and
saying in a statement this is a
terrorism-related matter in which the
jewish community was targeted and is
being investigated by the joint
terrorism task force president biden
also reacting and using the incident to
push for stricter gun control
this was an act of terror
this is an act of terror
and allegedly he purchased it on the
street now what that means i don't know
but you can't stop something like this
if someone is on the street buying
something from somebody else on the
street
except that there's two there's so many
guns that have been sold of late it's
just ridiculous and
it's because of the failure us to focus
as hard as we should and as consistently
should on gun purchases gun sales ghost
guns and a whole range of things that
i'm trying to do
greg i want to go to you and have you
listen first to andy mccarthy who
described what the fbi might have been
thinking
for too many years the bureau
has been hypersensitive to
islamist organizations and they and
their demagoguery and the way they react
and i think they take them to be like
the voice of muslim americans across the
country which they're not uh and they
try to you know sort of
couch their
words in a way that's not offensive to
those organizations when i think they
should just tell us what happened
i mean just to state the obvious perhaps
yeah clearly uh everybody here is
completely wrong
this was the work of an angry parent
fresh from a school board meeting
radicalized by tucker carlson to join
the oath keepers and head to a synagogue
i can't believe you people see don't see
through this but andy eddie mccarthy
he's absolutely right there's a
hypersensitivity the fbi is more
concerned by the perceptions of them
being seen as intolerant especially now
in the age of woke uh that's more
important than actually speaking the
truth and you're seeing this
all throughout the white house and and
joe and uh and joe biden especially is
that they're they're under the thumb of
twitter and they're kind of that's kind
of where they anticipate their reactions
meanwhile normal people people who turn
on the news who aren't you know who
don't work in politics or media they
only see two variables the two variables
are synagogue islamic terrorists there
are no other there's no other context
necessary for them they don't need to to
see the big picture
you don't need the big picture here
you've got the two two variables but
then what happens is they they can make
the conclusion that this is work of an
islamic terrorist in an anti-semitic
attack but once you add the other
variables woke media woke twitter woke
politics what you end up happening is
well this appears unrelated to
anti-semitism or terror it really is
about getting guns off the street and
the real terrorist is perhaps the nra so
this is what happens
the american public can see through that
and joe can prattle on about gun control
but his party killed gun control you
cannot energize criminals while
disarming the public right between
demonizing the police the funding
ideology the defunding
ideology lawful gun owners are going to
be buying more guns
jesse one of the things about stricter
gun control is okay fine you can find
you want to have that discussion but
what about stricter border enforcement
or customs and border patrol protection
on immigration because
this guy this terrorist entered the
united states on december 29th and now
you have uk
officials interviewing two teams today
that perhaps some sort of connection
what was the intel chatter that was
going on before this
we're going to have to ask biden that
question when he holds his news
conference on wednesday this guy wasn't
on your radar mr president
you gave him a visa two weeks ago to
come into this country what kind of visa
was it
did you vet him was he on a watch list
usually the feds are all over these
people and then they do a raid
immediately in england with associates
or people affiliated with them so
scotland yard didn't know anything about
this mi6 had no clue about this guy this
guy buys a hot gun off the street two
weeks after he gets here who was the guy
i bought the gun from they don't even
know how he died who shot him there's a
lot of suspicious things about the story
and a lot of unanswered questions and
hopefully joe has at least one of those
answers in the next 48 hours because he
should be asked about this but dana
if there's someone for a national
radical muslim who comes into this
country and holds jewish people hostage
at a synagogue and then demands the
release of an al-qaeda prisoner
the fbi
comes out and says we can't rule out
trump supporters
think about that you know we don't know
if his motive was white rage
or the russians i mean that's really
what they did here and that's how the
fbi does it that's by the book remember
dana the fbi has said
publicly that the number one domestic
terror threat yeah are white
supremacists so when there's something
like this happen they can't rule
anything out
everybody's a suspect dana you can't
actually get mad because listen we don't
want to cause any more islamophobia here
because again this happened in texas god
forbid there's a backlash
vigilante's in that dirty southern state
we can't have that we have to we can't
we have to protect peaceful
muslims not peaceful trump supporters
but peaceful muslims those are the
people who we really really have to
protect it's all backwards
harold could you listen to um two
representatives of the jewish community
their reaction to how it was first
characterized
are you kidding me the hostage taker did
not go to a mcdonald's he didn't go to a
shopping mall he went to a synagogue a
synagogue attacked a synagogue by
someone who's trying to free a terrorist
for god's sake and for the fbi to say
yeah this was not about the jewish
community
hey it was about the jews for god's sake
harold your your thoughts today
well first off uh happy king day two i
don't necessarily
uh see how
from the outset it was not perceived as
an attack on the jewish people i i think
about three years ago a little over
three years ago in pittsburgh a tree of
life
where the attack happened the deadliest
attack on the jewish community in the
united states
uh i even think about immanuel amy
church in charleston south carolina when
another act of hate uh was perpetrated
for me the bigger issue is the one that
jesse raised i don't know
how he got into the country uh he seemed
to have been banned this person
from a courthouse in his own hometown
um i would seem to me to to to to to
raise some flags or raise some fears
i don't blame it though i don't i
wouldn't go quite as far as yes in
blaming this on bite and i think our
intelligence operations and apparatus
have to understand what communication uh
was not there where was their
communication that was not there i give
the fbi a little credit this more this
evening because they did clarify and
correct their statement but i would hope
whatever processes they have and we
don't we're not privy to remember this
thing i think was streaming live uh and
finally i give that rabbi who is the
real hero in all of this how he was able
to help those hostages escape and how he
was able to distract
uh this this terrorist
well one of the reasons he was able to
do that kennedy is because many of these
synagogues have gone through training to
make sure that they are prepared to deal
with it the other thing is harold
mentioned it was being live streamed
it is curious we haven't heard yet
during this investigation what sort of
phone the uh killer had
uh well i guess he didn't kill anyone
but the perpetrator
what kind of phone did he have and are
the tech companies cooperating to make
sure that we can get the information i
bet they are they usually do but you
know you're absolutely right to question
the fbi about this because they didn't
just clarify their statement
they did a complete 180 here because
they got it so wrong the ft the fbi has
done more to tarnish the trust and law
enforcement people in this country have
for local and federal law enforcement
than the progressive defund the police
movement and you know they've been
pretty awful about these things and for
that meathead spokesperson to come out
and say it had nothing to do with the
fact that this was a synagogue a jewish
house of worship
that's absolute baloney and you know
everyone should be outraged about this
you have to be straightforward with
people
that's the only way we can make society
safer is if you're honest with people
instead of trying to shellack things and
it reminds me of how the fbi dropped the
ball after interviewing olympic gymnasts
and putting that testimony uh in
a file for 18 months so the person who
was essentially accused of some horrific
sexual assault went out and assaulted
more victims so the fbi has egg all over
its face and it's not okay because they
issued a massive clarification hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else